[Music]
there's no control of migration on this
border at all
we've got more people coming in so this
year's 200 000.
huge numbers
and it costs around 40 000 pounds for
each individual in the first year
that's about 8 billion
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is the
founder for the center for migration and
economic prosperity stephen wolfe
welcome to trigonometry thank you very
much guys i really appreciate you
bringing me out uh it's really great to
have you on the show before we get into
the conversation i'll tell everybody a
little bit about who are you how are you
where you are what is the journey that
brings you to be sitting here talking to
us well i'm a man so from your colleague
over here we've already had the kind of
manchester liverpool argument
born in manchester um and i grew up
in a couple of council estates one more
side which most people recognized as
being from the riots of the 80s a pretty
pretty rough area and then growing up in
whittington
near a park where i used to do break
dancing and football so that was that
was a brilliant thing
um i was lucky enough to have a family
a irish grandmother english grandfather
a black american
grandfather grandfather and a jewish
grandmother who
um
kind of even though we lived on a
council estate believed that the way
forward to get on
was by education and just keep pushing
never allowing people to define you by
who you are and just keep climbing that
ladder but being decent along the way
trying not to be nasty to others it's
not always the way that the world works
and so we read a lot and i won a
scholarship to a what was then a grammar
school became a private school saint
pete's from there university studied law
in aberystwyth went on became a
barrister uh won a number of
international awards across the globe
for debating uh went to the world
championships uh you know got to the
quarterfinals where gov was actually
judging so you know number of people
with those and
that was always a fascinating part um
after being a barrister
for a number of years i then moved into
the city of london so not really very
far from here worked in canary wharf
worked over the city and i moved into
hedge funds
regulatory law became general counsel
so by the time i decided to move into
the heady world of brexit politics and
leaving the european union and joining
uk which for many was a
you know it's a kind of well what's this
kind of mixed race working class boy
joining this racist ukip party about as
it was around 2010-ish
um
it was it was very strange for me to
have been working in this environment
the city
and doing some really big transactions i
mean i worked on one of the deals when
um guys had got fined uh barclays banker
got fired about i think it was about 500
million by the u.s authorities and i had
to do their global market conduct policy
that was big big issues and there
through the crash and then i went into
politics and i campaigned
for brexit and joined ukip
obviously
at one stage looking at the leadership
from there and you know many people look
online and see what happened but we i
left and became independent
spent five years which was fascinating
really interesting seeing
how global politics interacted with
european politics and uk politics
loved campaign
just
meeting
ordinary people during that campaign
from 2010 right through 14 elections
um right through 15 and then the 16
referendum where ordinary people felt
that they were empowered
that they had a voice that they
generally were going to be listened to
and this timely elites had a chance to
have a kiki and hopefully change their
minds about how they viewed them
that was one of the most exhilarating
parts of my my life seeing freedom in
action and real
real freedom for within people's spirits
and hearts and
but we are where we are now um i then um
lost my businesses that i saved for a
rainy day uh through covid and uh then
decided well can't i have an
eight-year-old i should be nine soon as
a father you just can't allow your
children to see you give up
and and i don't think it's easy in this
country to give up because if you do
then it's an easy slide into absolutely
nothing i i came from nothing i could go
back to nothing but i don't really want
to
so i decided to try and um rebuild
through one of the issues which i think
will not go away which is immigration
and where voices of people are still
being ignored certainly
with the channel migrant crisis that we
have at the moment and i established the
center for migration and economic
prosperity so i think that's probably
tried to put 54 years into you know less
more than 54 seconds i'm a phrase yeah
well you've done very well to do that
and we want to talk to you about class
and immigration particularly but it just
occurred to me that one of the things
that you obviously would have an
interesting perspective on given your
background uh and your heritage
what do you make of the way we talk
about race in our society at the moment
you are divisive absolutely and it's it
is very much us and them
it's either that you are a
pro-migrationist open door and therefore
you're kind and you're warm and you're
generous
and if you support um any form of
controlled migration whether it's
through border controls review visas
through the immigration act that's going
through then you are a racist as a
xenophobe and your anti-human being and
you should therefore be pushed aside i
think there's also a huge amount of
class involved in that if you're well
off
if you're university educated with an
opportunity of life to be able to
benefit here in the uk or be able to
move around the global networks as i
have fortunately been able to work in
the u.s work in hong kong if you're able
to do that too then you're part of a
global elite which relies seriously
heavily on the low income and wages of
migrants coming in filling the jobs that
you like getting into the coffee shop as
you turn up at the airport you know
getting your taxi that's taking you
there all of these uh
what's regarded as low income jobs that
you wouldn't deem to do
yourself
but you will insult the home
people of that country
and here in the uk might predominantly
be regarded as white working class
individuals as gammons or whatever will
insult you
because you won't do those jobs
rather than considering why don't they
do their jobs isn't it because perhaps
they
the incomes of those jobs are not
sufficient for them to have a family in
a house in the area that they want to
live in
so
i think that divisive element that is
clearly there as part of an elitist
strategy to divide
particular political parties labor does
it more
i think the liberal democrats
and the greens do it to
consolidate their intellectual base as
they do so
but i think it's also been used and we
might come on to that with like black
lives matter and all the rest of it is a
very
violent vehicle now for division in this
country to try and
manipulate the minds of individuals that
those who don't have this kind of global
elitist idea and i do believe it's
organized by
large corporates who benefit the most
and those in large international
organizations who benefit from the
billions that are being put into
migration issues they're the ones who
benefit the most and we need to create
now an intellectual divide between
people
stephen why is it that these elites that
let's call them that why is it they
don't understand this why is it that
they don't get it because to me it's a
fairly simple concept yeah but if you
live in the lap of luxury
if you're just going to get up in the
morning get on and let's just take it as
you part of what all will said in 1984
the 13 of the outer ring or the outer
level
if you're going off in the morning and
you get your train and you hit into the
city of london and you're a banker or a
hedge fund lawyer or you're an
accountant there or one of the it guys
who are doing really really well
then for you
it's
not something that you will see on a
day-to-day basis i mean you're getting a
reasonable bonus and a good salary to be
able to buy a house in a nice area which
doesn't have the impact that you see in
mass migration
so if you take my
street where i lived in manchester in in
in
kind of whittington at the end but
even if you take it right back to my
side in my side it was predominantly
those who'd come from the west indies
who were living in there
and that has changed somewhere over time
you know you get somalians have come in
certain parts of hume but if you look at
down whittington
that was predominantly white working
class and irish working class and the
immigrants there were those who come
over or like my grandmother at the age
of 14 to work for the nuns
and
all those who families were first or
second generation
similar types of culture you know a
christian judeo basis you might say okay
they're all white fair enough but so was
like 98 of the population until roughly
just after the 60s that's what england
was based upon
now if you go down to the same streets
it is
if i'm right in terms of the
demographics it's more pakistani based
community now that is is stretched
across from the 11th human long side
coming down now many of them have lived
there for a long time they've got
successful businesses they are working
in jobs nothing to say they don't do the
same level of hard work but the
communities are different
they have a different religion so that
might clash people might say i don't
like that religion some might say i love
it
the idea is that community is no longer
the same
now that
change there which impacts the working
class
and even the lower middle class more
than the upper upper classes is that
when i leave university
i might have had a boyfriend or a
girlfriend who is from bangladesh
or from abu dhabi or from china
and they're going off to be a banker in
new york
well that's fine we've had the same
intellectual levels and we're interested
in the same things let's get into a big
house let's get in the great bonuses
let's be able to go off to the hamptons
that we can't find our our jets to dubai
and have our five-star holidays it
doesn't really matter to them because
the poverty levels at the bottom
they never see
they don't have to go into those areas
they don't even have to get drugs in
those areas now because you can probably
get you know a drone or uber to be able
to sorry
you know there have been one or two
cases where people
but you know what i mean it's on the
internet and people could send it they
called it for right i'm not anyway let's
not go down there just in case it's
picked up as being something that
but but you know the point so they're up
there they don't need to and if they
want their drugs or they you know
whatever it is they they put a call in
and someone flies in in a pretty nice
car and whatever it's delivered to them
so they're separate
they're insulated from the consequences
of the right absolutely yeah of course
they are and they're insulated by their
own
wealth and ease of life that is that
comes with having that division and then
it comes to something i think is
intellectually there for them
i've been trying to ponder an aspect
about it when you read i think it's in
england by england by george orwell um
where he talks about even you know in
the 1900s
how the middle class of england would
rather be more comfortable talking to a
foreigner than someone from the
working-class estates of their own and
they
have more of an affinity of that
and i i generally think that there are
two aspects about that one is class and
snobbery so
racism is something that is a cultural
aspect about britain we can go right
back to beyond the romans to see
evidence of that
but so is snobbery
snobbery is the second pillar
of our cultural heritage
and it is something that firmly fits
into the class system that we have
developed over years
so you can quite easily sit at a
conversational table and say those brits
don't want to do the work they just
don't want to do the work they're too
lazy they're too thick they're too
stupid the same arguments that floated
through through brexit
and
and i think for them it's an easy thing
to divide look at me
haven't i done well
didn't i start my business on my own and
now look at my house and you know i've
got my second home down in devon it's
wonderful not like that just come over
there
you know won't get up off them in the
morning and do a job so it's that
snobbery element
to protect themselves insulate
themselves and therefore
that permeates downwards from the very
elites who have real wealth
where they really benefit from mass
migration to those in the next tear down
who think well we need to follow along
those lines but it's always because they
are as you say hidden from the
consequences at the bottom level of
housing hospitals schools wages
all of those are impacted at the lower
levels
never at the top
hey francis have you decided what to get
your dad for father's day same thing as
always a couple of points down the dog
and duck plus a new brexit means brexit
car sticker to replace the one i got him
last year mate brexit was in 2016. do
you not think he might want something a
bit more up to date like a new ridge
wallet this is mine it's smooth sleek
stylish and it can hold 12 cards and
there's also a clip on the back for cash
as well it's not going to create a bulge
in your trousers like those bulky old
wallets you'll make your dad look like a
top level player
great idea he can also put his brexit
sticker on it which means a problematic
older ladies are gonna love him
yeah okay the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
just one wallet for the rest of your
life rich are so confident in their
product they'll give you 45 days to test
drive their wallet that means you can
get the wallet use it and if you don't
like it you can return it in 45
days unlike brexit because ridge are
such great guys they're going to give
you 15 off and free worldwide shipping
and returns that's 15
off and free worldwide shipping and
returns to take advantage of this
incredible offer go to ridge.com forward
slash trigger that's ridge.com forward
slash trigger and use our special promo
code which is of course trigger
and
the problem is because they're impacted
what happens is
it just seems to be this chasm
that means that they just can't
empathize and we saw it with covid
i remember talking to a friend of mine
who you know works at a very very welter
to public school you know very in favor
of lockdowns very in favor that you know
this was a good thing and a positive
thing
he just couldn't get his head around the
fact that this was crippling ordinary
people and ordinary people's businesses
just couldn't get his head around it
yeah
and and they just don't seem to
understand now because the divisive
element in our society even look at the
economics of it i i think
i look at how fortunate i i am
in the sense that
born in 1967 we still had a grammar
school system that
enabled large numbers of working class
uh men predominantly men i say at the
time but certainly women were coming
through at those stages through the 60s
and 70s to start getting into the
educational levels now i went through
law but you'll see that there's some
great actors that followed similar
routes to be able to do that you saw
them coming into the civil service you
also have the second element that was
the what i regard the the
the transitory unification of britain
that was caused by the first and second
world war
where if everybody looked at duty of the
queen
there was huge numbers of people who had
duty of the crown and the country at
their heart because they'd risk their
lives for it in the second world war
they'd literally watch people die next
them
i mean i i talk about my grandfather um
sitting in a pub on his own in the green
end in manchester which is gone now for
housing due to large-scale migration
let's get rid of it and just build more
houses you're going to see huge huge
amounts more under in the country now
and he would sit there and become silent
um
when he and you knew everyone said leave
jim alone when he do that with his
brandy and whatever because he was
memorizing remembering
the death and destruction
but that unification also came through
with the grammar school system in the
60s and 70s where this this was
supportive element for the nation as a
whole
and more and more people like myself got
through
and i don't see that now yes more people
are going into to university but what
we've seen
is that income division
has instead of what we saw in the 60s
and 70s
becoming more spread the total income
and capital of the country being spread
out more it's now contracted anyone will
tell you that the rich have definitely
become richer over the past
10 15 years maybe even 20.
and certainly the middle classes have
become squeezed not just here but in the
united states more visibly perhaps in
australia but it's happening all across
the commonwealth in those countries and
why is that happening
and it's happening predominantly because
we've got large-scale mass migration
which is increasing the numbers of lower
income individuals
and we've had the use of stock markets
and
capital growth in housing that is
protecting those who already have those
assets
so they don't need to see us
they're quite happy to be separated from
us and
i'm trying to your audience will pick up
on on a movie there was a movie where
literally um the wealthy lived in space
and they just took the assets from those
down on on earth
and the chasm there was was actually
space
and i think that was a metaphor
for expressing where they are now
the chasm is that they're sitting
whether it's in their
park lane at houses or
sitting in the big flats in new york
overlooking the parks there they've got
their space between them and us
and they might turn around and say oh
look i'm going to have a wonderful ball
or a party
you know for the charity events
but that's just really solving their
souls solving their consciences
and actually also making themselves look
good
and the politicians that go along with
that from the political parties whether
it's the labour party or democrats
in the united states they're actually
also
working and conniving with those who
really just don't care
stephen you you talk about mass
immigration
i think before we carry on we should
maybe explain to people
what is actually going on because for a
lot of people
uh they'll have a particular view of it
but it will be local to them or it will
be based on the headline that they've
read yeah now i came to this country
from russia in 1995.
at that point i think the level of
immigration was about 60 000 the year 70
000 a year or something like that yes
and at that time three percent of the
british public thought that immigration
was a major issue in other words people
felt fairly comfortable with what was
happening they didn't feel
uh particularly disrupted their lives
were not being damaged by people like me
coming
what have we seen in the last 25 30
years well the level of net migration
that's coming is consistently over 200
to 250 000 now for 10 years or more
so you're adding an extra 250 000 that's
coming into the to the country now some
of them have come for students some are
coming for work others are family
reunions but the numbers are huge so
what that's doing is increasing the
population
then
that's what we might call
the legal migration levels
then you've got what some will call
illegal
immigration stroke asylum on there and
it's the argument that they're illegal
until they make an application for
asylum i i don't really want to make
that distinction as such what i will say
is that there is certainly illegal
immigration into the country but there's
also genuine asylum seekers and we must
always must make that clear distinction
between them do we know approximately
what sort of numbers we're talking about
which is not people who are genuine
people fleeing terror and war and
whatever but people who are
capitalizing let's say an opportunity
that i don't blame them for right
they're trying to make a better life for
themselves i don't think any of us can
make that no argument but want to do the
same if you could
exactly
so but what kind of numbers are we
talking about on an annual basis with
just the purely illegal immigration that
we don't think is genuine asylum seekers
oh right okay well i think what we have
to try and work back backwards if we can
um
because
the the uk's statistical bodies
cannot make any assessment what is
illegal migration in fact they just
published a report on the 24th of
february which almost at the top you say
we cannot tell you what illegal
migration is into this country what they
will tell you is that migration flows
from people coming on boats as which is
popular at the moment but they've been
coming in backs of lorries trains and
planes
for decades now so and some of those
will be asylum seekers some of those
will be illegal they'll be overstayers
who will come over on a visa for
education and disappear into the ether
they're illegal
and what we will then have is
other levels in between that so they're
trying to say you can't fix the numbers
the statistical bodies are trying to
formulate a way in which they can assess
that but we do have research from the us
from the uk from holland that has
been reported even to an extent
i think that about 15 years ago we had
reports that i've been looking at
recently that would indicate that we
have between 600 000 and 1.2 million
illegal migrants in this country
those are huge numbers
and when you look at what's coming over
on on the boats at the moment so we
start just on the boats
891 in 2019 8 000 not in 2020 18 000
in 2021 this year they're estimating
that we might have 60 to 100 000 coming
on that boat route wow okay you add then
that we've had about 25 000 coming
through legal routes from syria and
we're setting up with afghanistan
so generally one could argue that we get
around 100 000 a year
that are coming in through all the
various routes to add on to the net
migration levels
many of those people will then move into
the asylum process of which
about 90 odd but 98 of them make the
application about 60 of them are
successful
but then we don't we don't remove those
who are unsuccessful
so you can have cataclysmic
issues by those who are not removed as
we saw with the attempted bomber in
liverpool
so we do know
that there are hundreds of thousands of
people out there who are not being
removed who failed
not only the asylum application but we
were not removing them now you can ask
why
people will argue that look actually
we've only got really on average around
35 to 40 000 a year
in terms of asylum applications that's
the same as came over through the boats
in sorry in the lorries and the vans
over the past
decades or so to an extent that is true
but that hides the overall picture of
those who get here overstay and hide etc
and i think what we're going to see now
is bigger numbers
so if we take afghanistan for example
afghanistan is wholly different
to syria
population is is twice as much
in afghanistan we spent trillions each
year building up a middle class or a
class that we thought we could work with
so these people have gone from the time
of when the taliban were in charge of 98
poverty level with just that two percent
we've actually added an extra 10 to half
a million people there who have now got
used to having televisions going to the
malls having restaurants all funded from
our taxpayers money effectively because
their economy doesn't create enough to
feed them and create that lifestyle for
them
they'll want to leave now the taliban
are making it clear that they can leave
in syria there's border controls in in
afghanistan there's not
we have drone footage that shows 1500
vehicles leaving in a day with 10 20
people on the backs of lorries paying 10
to the taliban border guards to get out
then paying 1500 sorry
5 000 us dollars to get them over into
turkey five thousand uh dollars again to
get them over so
1500 5000 to get them over to cali and
then 5 000 euros to get them into the uk
about average 12 000 pounds some of them
can pay for that because they've had
savings or they sell their watches or
jewelry
others can't
but the
why we're expecting large numbers to
flow
is because they're all still the same
numbers coming from iran and ira and
iraq
about 84 of everybody that comes over on
the boats are from those two countries
and those routes are now well drawn
the people traffickers
who are a separate body mainly to the
drug traffickers or interlinks at
certain stages for protection elements
where they pay a tithe to do so
they can now allow those numbers to come
through
so if you expect this year
the conservative estimates are 60 000
the median aspects to a hundred thousand
i don't think that's unsubstantiated
plus we're going to have to take large
numbers of ukrainians in as well
and the numbers there are estimated
between
you know 50 to 100 000 so this year's
200 000.
huge numbers
and it costs around forty thousand
pounds for each individual in the first
year
that's about eight billion
if we take all those numbers in one year
so there's costs there's housing where
are we going to look after them where
are we going to feed them so it's really
significant things that government has
to have policies for stephen i think one
of the things that a lot of people
watching and listening to this will
struggle to reconcile is i think i think
most of us do and i certainly do is on
the one hand everyone in this room is a
descendant of immigrants
i am a first generation immigrant
francis mum's an immigrant you talked
about your background our staff the same
how do we reconcile the desire to
protect people who are fleeing difficult
situations war
conflict murder
torture all of that horrible stuff that
happens elsewhere in the world and i
desire to be compassionate because we
are
incredibly privileged and
extraordinarily fortunate to be living
in the uk in the west more broadly we're
rich we're safe our countries are stable
they're you know
democratic you might argue right like we
enjoy tremendous privilege and it is a
natural human thing i think to to feel
compassion and empathy for people who
don't have that and who want to have it
i would love every person in the world
to be as wealthy and as comfortable as
we are i would and i think most people
would
how do we reconcile that
with the practical reality of what
happens to a country when there is this
level of churn and rapid change and
uh the security issues that come with
immigration from certain parts of the
world etc etc how do we how do we square
that circle in our heads it's not going
to be an easy thing to square because
you have to look at your heart and your
head in terms of this so let's try and
break it down if i if i can
i
do believe that we got to have
legislation in place and of course we've
got the international agreements with
the un
uh
refugees regulations and laws that
enable people as we're seeing now
a genuine asylum issue happening in
ukraine that deals with that and i think
that's perfectly fair every country who
signs up to that has to have a
responsibility in order to treat people
fairly and look after them and
we then need to assess the global net
global issues
so the u.n are estimating we've got
something around 66 million people
moving around
in terms of this
a migrant flow illegal or asylum but
generally moving to get out of their
homes
the issues that we have to face is a
recognition
of
modernity of our life and the ease of
travel and technology
technology has been sending messages to
people in small parts of africa that
never had televisions to say
look at london the streets are paved at
gold for those in guatemala where whole
villages have left to cross over the
borders into texas the us place of
land of honey and gold again sort of
thing so their lives are distinctly
better when they get here in the sense
that they're they're not struggling in
the way for food and daily living
so that's an economic
migrant issue so
the question we have to ask ourselves is
are we going to accept everybody
genuine refugees
and economic migrants and just allow
everyone to move because if you do that
you've got good examples of what happens
in germany when merkel said i will open
the borders they've now had over two and
a half million people since 2014. it's
an extra cost of between 10 and 15
billion a year to that nation
and you could see the economic changes
you say we're wealthy nations
but we're not really
look at the average salaries of some of
the people in the north of england
i keep pointing this out the difference
between living in london where people's
average salaries seem to be around 40 50
000 a year compared to 20 25 in the
you could still buy houses for 80 000
in the north of england where it that
wouldn't even get you a front door i
think somewhere
in london you know
so the poverty levels up there and i
don't see people going into the really
poor areas of of england they kind of
ignore it
it just doesn't exist to them
and so
we are creating huge poverty gaps here
in the uk by importing those people who
are incredibly poor from elsewhere so is
the solution to say let's just open the
doors
well in that case you're only going to
get about 20 odd countries in the world
they're going to be able to take the
numbers
look at the populations of the world
billions
we said let's open the door those
billions will want to move
and what happens to our economies then
do we stay wealthy
i don't think so we're already becoming
the most dense
country in europe i think there was a
over the past few months we're still
balancing between holland ourselves as
england is the most dense place when
they come here they concentrate into
certain areas london birmingham the
cities primarily
but if you look at places like
winchester where i've come from we're
building huge numbers of housing four
thousand five thousand six thousand
houses we've got an estimate for
building another fifty seven thousand
houses
over the past few years we're on average
building around 165 000 houses a year
and yet house prices aren't falling and
we still have people living on the
streets we still have a quarter of a
million people living in homeless
shelters and one bedroom flats and bed
sets
we can't build enough houses to
accommodate those already living here
and expect to be able to do that when
coming through
so
there are no easy solutions let's get
this right no one should say just
closing the border will solve the
problem overnight because then we are
disregarding our responsibilities to
those in other parts of the world
for a start we shouldn't be developing
war-like situations with other countries
we shouldn't be interfering in nations
to do regime change as we've done in how
many countries over the past 10 years
and someone estimated that at one stage
the cia are involved in 130 operations
130 countries where they're operating to
try and do regime change or get their
particular people in power well maybe
china's doing the same
maybe other countries are involved in
that but every time you do that you
create conflict you get armed war you
get murder you get death
and when that happens people want to
flee
so our responsibility as a nation
should actually as the united nations
not be just trying to dole out cash to
salvage your conscience for the problems
that you're creating
you should be looking at how we can
create peace and stability in those
countries first and foremost by stop
saying we're backing the big corporates
to we want them to take over your
country we want all your assets and
actually leave it to the people in
charge and then help them create
economies in their countries that grow
and then support their nations and those
people want to stay
now that's where i say it's not going to
be easy
because we cannot as a small nation
absorb the world's mass migration
from conflict to economic migration and
if they're right maybe environmental
issues as well we can't do that without
creating an even bigger gap between
those at the bottom and those at the top
we must start looking at how we can try
and create a peaceful environment and
invest in nations to develop their own
economies
if we can do that then we go some way to
try and solve those issues because it's
a bit hypocritical of us saying to
syrian refugees you're not allowed in
when
you look at what's happened to their
homeland you know which we have played a
part in absolutely i mean
no you talked about it i mean
in in terms of the ukraine and syria but
afghanistan
in iraq in iran
there is a game that's being played by
guys who and women you know and it's
equally the same i saw it in the united
states when i'm over there people call
them the neocons some will call them
world economic forum others will call
them the military industrial complex
yeah i'm sure they're all connected in
some ways they all go to the same
parties they're like go ski in the same
parts of aspen you know the sender kids
to the same universities and schools you
they know where they are they date each
other that's what they do but as they at
the end of the day have pressed the bomb
button to murder someone in the country
thousands of miles away that they won't
see and they get into their big car and
they go to their house party in the
hamptons at the end of the day
they're responsible
for the transformations and they may sit
there thinking with a glass of you know
big cup of jd i think it's wonderful
what a great day i've had i'm protecting
our environment you're not
what you're doing is protecting your
environment your personal space your
personal bank account this big frame of
a house that you're living in
you really don't give a damn about the
people that have died in those countries
those who are having to move across and
pay gangsters
to be able to get them out of those all
the people living in estates that i grew
up in
who have to suffer the consequences
that's the big issues that we have
that's why i got involved in politics
that's why i'm still knocking around
but
that subject is a very taboo one
the fact that we're having this
conversation you wouldn't see it being
had in a lot of other places with this
frankness
why is that
because they
someone's just opened my eyes to
something called the overton window i
mean i've got to study it a little bit
more to try and get a full grip about it
because i don't like to just take a
theory without trying to understand the
full background about it but what to an
extent that i get from that is that
it's okay for us to have a little bit of
discontent with the elites that allow us
a little bit of freedom and movement to
do so and if you
move up the ladder too much then they'll
cut you off at the knees um you know one
can argue that you saw that
with the replacement between um martin
luther king and malcolm x
during the during the 60s
representing two wings
of the black freedom movement one which
is the middle class and one was very
much a working-class environment and and
when both of them started to come
together it is argued that they moved on
from saying it's just white versus black
which fitted into a really nice scenario
for the fbi and the elites to to
dissect them and diversify them but when
they started talking about the economics
of what the people lived in
and how we should be changing the
economics of the united states soon
after they were killed
now one could argue that was coincidence
one could argue that was planned
but what we get with scenario in our
country is that whether you've got those
threats at the top when people start
talking about the economics and
combining all this together
the window of opportunity to express it
in our modern window whether this is the
overton window or not
is reduced
so when i would go onto tv on the bbc
it'd often be like three people pro mass
migration and calling me a racist
xenophobe and not caring
against myself
now i could handle it i mean i don't
mind i've got you know kind of broad
shoulders i mean when you come off the
estate you know you've had a lot worse
coming at you than someone who's been
educated that you know oxbridge and
shouting a few nasty words
sticks and stones can break my bones not
a word that comes from someone from
saint hilda's you know and so
that is that is why they don't like the
frankness
they don't like the frankness because it
challenges them
to try and move out of their comfortable
environments the task for most of us
whether it's in politics we talk about
this
is to try and bring out the reality of
of the overall impacts to the
communities in the home state
and then separate it from those who are
benefiting
from this
and i'm now starting
to get a bit of funding from people to
start doing research on
what i call the immigration industry
there's a huge number of people benefit
from this
so far
i can see just on easy money
very easily identifiable money that
we've got 250 million pounds to 500
million pounds a year
being handed out to organizations that
help asylum applicants
and immigrants in this country
so those are just the ngos these are
charities as they call themselves that
come out so that's a lot of people
getting a lot of money from that
then there are um universities that get
funding for research projects
and those research projects often come
out and say look
mass migration creates huge amounts of
gdp for us there's no gmp difficulties
but they're the ones getting the funding
organizations like myself
which i would need two or three people
to be able to help research at the same
level the universities have don't get
anything near that
so then they've got the material that
they can sow for the research
that they can use through the
polls that they do and then that gets
into the press with their friendly
universe
friendly journalists who many of them
might have gone to university with who
then print what they've got so they
perpetuate that industry of course
you've got the lawyers that are making
money out of it through legal aid
get a divorce try and get your child
back from your wife or your child back
from your husband no legal aid there for
you but you do get it if you're an
asylum
so there are some genuine costs going
out to people who are making a lot of
money out of this
and if you look at corporates
i mean
it's mere serco and clear spring houses
limited signed a contract for 10 billion
with the government to house those
in initial accommodation and then
long-term accommodation
10 billion
but that was before we've had the latest
mass influx and now we're spending 4.7
million pounds a day
housing in hotels and bed cities
and i'll give you an example of someone
who pointed out to me said look i'm in a
poor area of the north
a guy came up and bought three houses
which might only be like two or three
bedroom houses and they've just housed
them
with those people coming from asylum
applicants
and they're getting double or triple for
that house than they would do from
someone paying on the local estate
hey constantin do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
stephen the the running theme through
what you're talking about is is the
an elite that is uninterested
uh or perhaps even actively
disinterested in the
needs and views of the rest of the
society yes
and i suppose uh i would argue that
a certain stratification of society is
always going to be the case and it's
inevitable it's human nature hierarchy
etc
but it seems to me that we have come to
a point where even a colossal shock like
brexit francis and i both voted remain
in that referendum we weren't
politically particularly switched on at
that point i would say
but that could have been a wake-up call
to the elites on this issue
i'm not sure how much i mean it might
have been a wake-up call but we've very
quickly moved on to other things and
we've just channeled those same
bitterness and division and everything
into covet and now ukraine and there'll
be next things to come but fundamentally
i see it all the time i remember talking
to a friend of mine who i knew through
my previous work it was i think she was
french and we were talking about brexit
and she was saying well i don't know i
don't know why why can't like in france
we just you know the people voted and we
went no we don't want this so we just
cancelled it and why can't they do that
here
and
you know
and she's not a bad person she's she's
she's a good girl you know there's not a
writer but
i just it make i i find it difficult to
understand how people can be so
self-obsessed and so ignorant because
you can be self-obsessed in the short
term but in the long term if you keep
alienating
your own voters and the people who
actually run the country by working and
you know doing everything that's not a
recipe for a good society down the line
and that's why you have to have gated
communities because you're terrified of
the poor people that live around you yes
and of course what happens now and
you'll you'll see that whether it's
gated communities whether it's the fact
that
on the streets of almost everywhere in
the uk now you're seeing video cameras
and technology being used to identify
who we are
you know you're following us on our
phones we're using big high-tech
companies to put into our phones and our
laptops we're seeing social media as a
way of actually knowing what we do and
what we say monitoring is a really
important part of keeping control when
you've got bigger bigger populations
it's not that we haven't had this
similar
sorry the kind of differences between
the poor and the rich create huge issues
in this country or any other country in
in the in the past one could argue when
you look at the french revolution that
was a classic example of where the
elites had just really gone too far
one could even step back into the ways
of the end of the roman era where you're
looking in era and others were just
expanded their empire too much but just
were enjoying the spoils of their
empires in rome by having a ball all the
time you know we know what was going on
in there they're kind of hedonistic end
days great parties
[Laughter]
i'm not sure i'd want to get involved in
some of them
but the animals were involved you know
that that keep me i might be a wolf but
keep me well out of that
to be honest
but even here in in in in britain as a
whole we've we've gone through our riots
wherever it's the simple thing is saying
the gin riots
because we've now decided that we don't
want everyone getting drunk on homemade
gin and we're losing revenue so we
created pub laws and licensing laws to
bring it back into pubs you know that
was a small element but we've had
challenges in this country the corn laws
created riots we've had
you know from the the levelers and the
diggers the pentridge martyrs to
when we go down to merthyr tidville we
had people killed in murder typical
simply for fighting for the right to
vote
you know we've had people challenging up
in peterloo my home time simply for
asking for the vote
we lost the lives of women
you know in in times of the
you know putting themselves under the
horse whether one of them put threw
themselves in front of a horse simply
for the right for vote for women
so we've had riots in this country
and even if you look at when in the
1980s
when we had the most tied riots the
saint paul's riots the riots coming down
in brixton all going up at the same time
with hesseltine coming up into level two
i understand the people i really do yeah
you certainly do when you put your
contracts into arms companies and
helicopter companies didn't you that
meant often killed and burned people in
the same time
they are we had riots
between those who said we've had enough
now
i don't think we're going to get that
many riots anymore because if you've
seen the way that our police are now
virtually paramilitary dressed as though
they're out some stormtrooper movie with
an arnold schwarzenegger you know or
star wars and you can see the way that
the army in france just
recently
for covid
demonstrations put 55 armed tanks
and there were i mean people were seeing
that 55 armed tanks on the streets of
paris not a city of love but a city of
war
we know what they've got behind us and
the training that they do
to be able to disarm us when we've got
this is if we complain about it it's not
going to be like the poll tax rights
with a few horses running over us this
is literally a militarized force now
that will be used against the people
and they practiced about it they have
training sessions about it they're quite
happy to use guns on as if they want to
so i don't think we're going to have
riots
and secondly there is still a genuine
belief in britain that we can transform
our nation through the ballot box and
brexit was that opportunity for them to
say okay let's step back let's go back
from what we saw with politics of the
past where we realized we've gone too
far and we can actually step out because
our country has had
that time as i said
you know from
the the removal of charles the first
and our own civil war we've had these
points upon our time when we gradually
got little bits of freedom
it was only what
i think 1930s when we got votes for the
women
there's an equal stage at the age of 18
and then we handed it over to the eu to
in my argument to to remove some of
those rights it took us hundreds of
years
to get universal suffrage at the age of
18. so we have had to fight to get there
brexit gave us an opportunity for them
to sit back and say okay
maybe we should allow this to happen and
we move on again and we start to
transform but they haven't you could
argue that kovitz come in you could
argue that what's happening in ukraine
or you could argue that all of these are
just great opportunities for us to
suppress that and let's go back to the
plan that we had and i think that's what
they're doing
do you think
brexit i don't want to use the word
betrayed because it's the wrong word but
you get one where i'm going with this
with the the initial promise what was
what was promised to people which was a
control of immigration yeah i i would
say you know in america they use the
word rhino for a republican in name only
we vote bino brexit in name only just
because we left the european parliament
and there's no meps there how much real
transformational change have we had vast
numbers of our regulations still aligned
with the eu most of the trade agreements
we have are based similarly along the
lines of the trade agreements that we
had with the eu and on immigration and
some of the big issues certainly no
major transformation
and where instead of using it as a real
massive energetic opportunity to enthuse
the british population
and and get ourselves out there to being
a transformative bright britain i think
we just contracted on ourselves in the
bitterness that came straight after that
the kind of
attack on those who got brexit from
those who were just a continuity remains
some people call them
and that's unfortunately just fed into
where we are
in immigration absolutely no movement
whatsoever
goodness no
there's no control of migration on this
border at all
we've got more people coming in and all
we did was say that european union
citizens have a slight restriction in
being able to get here those who are
already here we ended up finding out
that we had more european union citizens
actually registered in the uk who've
been given permanent rights to remain
so it's not like we've removed them and
and tossed them over the border as was
concerned about and yes we're going to
kick them all out if you remember some
of the arguments through that we're
never going to do that
and it wasn't sensible to do that either
that's not the sort of nation that we
are
it's about moving together working
together and recognizing where we are in
the difficulties that we had and then
saying okay time to sit back
let's assess where we are we've got
housing needs we've got hospital needs
we've got transport needs we've got to
feed the population
now we know where we are let's try and
manage the migration levels let's work
out how we can create an economy that
can be vibrant enough let's see if we
can utilize those people who are already
here
who are first and second and third
generation indians to help us with the
trade deals and trade with india let's
look at those like yourself you know to
be able to do trade deals with russia
and open up cross businesses trust me i
would not be very good on that i'm not
that popular but i see what you're
saying the point is we have an
indigenous community here people that it
embedded in here we should have been
giving them the tools and the
opportunities through government to go
out and do that stephen how much of this
is about guilt
because there is a narrative in britain
that's i don't know if it's always been
the case it wasn't
so certain wasn't noticeable to me when
i first came here as a kid
which which is that
britain is bad it's a bad country it it
colonized it invaded it enslaved it
profited from the misery it went all
around the world and oppressed people it
brought them over here in in terrible
conditions and they were treated very
badly when people came you know no
blacks no irish no dogs whatever the
slogans were all of that
we are guilty
we've done wrong and now
the most important thing is that we are
tone for our sins and frankly if we can
self-flagellate and punish ourselves
even better even better
well yes absolutely and i think
there is
uh guilt in terms of our historical
context of britain in terms of the way
that we went out and struck an empire
but name me many western countries that
didn't do the same look at belgium the
way that they absolutely massacred
people in the congo you know you have
italy who's done the same portugal and
spain in south america
not just western countries by the way
not just western the muslim world was a
colonizing world the russian empire was
a colony the muslim world had the the
control over the slave trade and you
know you also look at parts of africa i
think it might be wrong
but someone said that the ashantis grew
wealthy on the trade of slaves being
able to enable them to be able to be
transported out so i think you know when
you're looking at um the slave community
as being a commodity
just like coffee or tea
and people were making money out of it
it goes back to the commercialization of
them
but should i then go to my house and
then get a whip and whip myself at the
back for something that someone did
hundreds of years ago it depends if
you're catholic or not
[Laughter]
let's not go down there
or if you just enjoy that kind of thing
yeah i know i heard there's certain
parties in london to get on with that
you know but at the end of the day the
communities today shouldn't be
responsible
and feel that kind of guilt for what
happened 200 years ago otherwise
i as a northerner
want to go and find the normans for
harrying the north and creating the
first genocide in this country
because that's what those which is
modern-day france did they wanted to
wipe out those who were opposing them do
we go to um bath and level bath now for
all the sins of slavery and rape and
pillaging
that the italian romans did in our
country do we dig up all our roads and
say we don't want those rooms because
that's what
guilt is and those who start pulling
down the statutes are only referencing
to one country
because it's about hatred of this
country
it's not about hatred of the other
countries for doing it and so i think
guilt is very very bad but guilt is
something that is really part and parcel
of our education system at the moment
i think clearly
there are those who feel guilty in the
academic circles and they're educated to
do that and when they come out it's all
now filtering through i mean i certainly
had
my own daughter talking about the
vikings and the normans and she's
starting to talk about that now at the
age of eight and nine and i can see
through it so what i do
is i have other books
that i start reading to her about the
history of england that i've collected
and and she sees a different angle not
from those that are in the academic
tombs
that are being pushed upon
are people of today
we should not forget
and that's we shouldn't forget what
happened because we forget what's
happened we can't use it today
to look forward about how we improve our
world
um
i'm trying to think of the
labour leader who in the 80s who was
pilloried for his bad dress and style
before before before before kinnick and
he used to say if you don't know about
history you don't know about our future
and i think we have to look at that and
analyze it and say yes what we did was
bad
but it doesn't mean we start dipping our
hands into our pockets now and taking
out the billions that should be helping
our own country in compensation to those
other countries
because it won't benefit them
we know that every amount of money that
we're handing over to those countries is
being used badly anyway
isn't it better to try and do what i
said at the beginning which is try and
find mechanisms globally in which we can
try and improve the profitability of
those countries
not just by dumping cash into them but
working for them to build their
environments build their economies
dumping cash and compensation isn't
gonna help because it'll just help the
elites in smaller countries there to
pocket it for themselves
stephen i'm listening to a lot of your
arguments and they strike me as quite
classically old-school left-wing
but a lot of them i can imagine you know
you know
barbara castle you know tony ben even
dare i say jeremy corbyn
apart from the mass immigration thing
talking about the very same things that
you're talking about
and yet you were this evil man who
wanted to be leader of ukip yeah what
what what's gone wrong with with the
left in politics in general well i think
in terms of the left uh driven by this
desire
blair mandelson
that they wanted to they recognized that
they were beginning to lose the vote of
the working-class male in particular and
the families of the north why because
there were no longer any culprits and we
were killing the steel industry and the
fishing industry was dying so they had
to make a political decision of where
they're going to get the votes for in
the future
so the votes they felt was easy pickings
was by manipulating university students
into voting for them the young people
are always more aggressively pro
progressive like the rest of us they
want to just help the world which we we
do but they think more with their heart
and they never think with their heads
that was their analogies and then mass
migration was another way we're going to
rub the right's face in this was one of
the comments that's often used and we
saw mass migration because statistically
here in the uk and in the us and in
canada is that my migrants who come here
first tend to vote labor or tend to vote
the left organization so for them
that was a political turning point away
from those
of my estates
who would say that some of the issues
that we've talked about the economic
issues that impact those on the lowest
incomes and the middle classes and the
ability to move up the ladder
we're no longer as important anymore the
way that we'll salve that is just give
them benefits
keep them away push them away with
benefits the lazy way out of doing it we
won't deal with the proper issues just
throw them cash and then we can look
good again
that was labor and that's modern labor
today
tony ben's arguments of socialism was
the first political book
that i ever had
and i still have it you know it's a bit
worn torn and all the rest of it and if
you looked at that the labor of then
were a laborer of looking after people
globally and internationally one could
argue that i don't want wars and i see
the global elites i might be a john
pilger type style
a viewpoints on some of that yes where
is this weird lefty coming into me but
on some issues social contract issues
the family the faith the flag that i saw
from my grandfather my grandmother come
here the integration into our country
those are parts that have been pilloried
by the left they hate us for that they
genuinely hate us and despise us we talk
about
a catholic or a christian religion in
the uk
if they talk about flag waving i mean
what's in the
rochester by-election there's an england
flag look at that how disgusting is that
you know they really don't like it
because for them
the the socialist internationalism is
not about anything that could be
positive patriotism
at all and positive patriotism can be a
really beneficial thing if you're
looking at how to improve our nation
the way that we put our hands in our
pockets for charities the way that red
nose day we come together all of those
are part of the historical aspects of
who we are as brits but for the labour
party in the left yes
i have that social contract maybe that's
what slightly dangerous to some of those
people who didn't want me in charge of
the political party at the time but
there was also an element that has been
captured by iran i think that's the
zeitgeist
that was there in the middle and that's
what we've seen
in the kind of separation
between modern left modern democracy
democratic parties sorry and those in
europe
where we now
their main supporters uh immigrants
first generation and second generation
university and the intellectual elite
what i call fabian socialists
and the traditional trade union
socialists
are not there
there are still some who might believe
in it but i think some of the
traditional trade unionists have been
bought off by the way that they can get
huge amounts of money and have a
reasonable lifestyle as well
or just forced out like paul embry
absolutely you know absolutely stephen
it's been a great conversation before we
ask you uh questions from our supporters
uh first of all tell everybody where
they can follow your latest work yes
and uh we'll we'll ask you our final
question as well yeah so if you go to
the center for migration and economics
prosperity website which is www dot cm
that's where most of the work will start
to come and from there you'll feed off
into the other works that i do around
that as well fantastic so we've got one
more question for you as always which is
what's the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be
well
i i think it's the way that we're
manipulating our young people out of the
concept of freedom
that we are watching our young people
becoming more and more intolerant and
accepting of that intolerance
way that they can have people at
universities saying you can't speak
on a platform
the way that we attack individuals if
we're not
um not in agreement with your view i
mean you look at those in the lgbt
movement who really championed it
who are now being banned from actually
being
you know standing up and talking about
the transgender issues for example
so there's something going on there
where we're feeling it's
quite easy to manipulate young people
into this kind of ideology that they all
uh agree with the greta thonberg
chanting brigade
whether this was started by tony blair
and that kind of movement whether we see
that kind of progressive elements that
was there in trudeau's way that he
wanted to manage
or the the truckers
it's this attempt to dissolve freedom
into us and them and your our pack but
it's done now at a younger age
and what we're seeing is a way that we
put masks on children weaponizing
children weaponizing our young people
over the arguments of transgenderism why
is it that we feel that you can take the
jesuit idea of getting when they're
young now being accepted in politics
instead of allowing them to live their
lives freely without politics
without any of our
adult views as children
and then at university and school being
given a wider birth of opportunities
that's what's the concerning element to
me because once you're changing where
we're seeing now the generation that
we're in which was enabled to have
a deeper conversations will become
narrower and more intolerant
steven will fantastic we're going to ask
you a couple of questions from our local
supporters but for now thank you very
much for coming on
thank you very much thank you for having
me i've really enjoyed it thank you so
as have we uh thank you for watching and
listening we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all them go at 7pm uk time
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast
take care and see you soon guys
in your opinion do you ultimately
believe that you dodged a bullet by not
becoming leader of ukip
you